(snap)
- Am I about to get surgery?
- I feel like eyelashes are
something I don't notice,
but when they are more defined I'm like,
"Oh, there's something
different about you today."
- I have two younger sisters,
and I just wanna experience, like,
what they went through.
- I'm a beautiful boy, okay,
everything is perfect on me
except for my eyelashes,
so if I can accentuate that, watch out.
- I'm Countney Casgraux,
I'm from GBY Beauty.
The lash extensions are applied
with a medical grade adhesive
that's safe for the eyes.
The benefits of lash extensions,
they open up your eyes,
it's less maintenance,
you always look beautiful,
and your lashes look sick.
- So I'm seeing my
girlfriend this weekend,
so I'm thinking of more natural.
I don't want her to break up with me.
- We'll keep them flirty.
- So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
have you look back at me
so I can apply this gel pad
to keep the bottom lashes down.
- Don't open until I
tell you to open them.
- Which is gonna be like an hour from now?
- Yeah, about an hour.
All right, so here we go. Ready?
- All right.
- So to do this you have to ambidextrous.
I dip it in the glue,
find a lonely little hair,
and then I just apply it to it.
- I read online it was gonna hurt.
- It should not hurt.
It's actually rather relaxing.
- Oh, whoa.
- Just a few more and we are good to go.
- All right.
(funky music)
- Oh!
(chuckles)
- Honestly, I never see my eyelashes.
- It's definitely much more
feminine than I'm used to,
but that's not necessarily a bad thing.
- Like, I could be a K-Pop star right now.
- I look like an anime character.
- Are your eyelashes longer?
- What's wrong with your eyes?
- You got's eyelashes, son!
- You can tell?
- Yeah.
- No you can't.
- They're very dark.
- Oh my goodness!
Those are beautiful!
- [Luis] Thank you!
- This eye is more
prominent than that eye.
- Uh oh.
- I saw you this morning and I was like,
"Is Luis wearing mascara?"
- Can I, can I feel them?
C'mere, I just wanna like,
- You like them, or no?
- No!
- Wait, really?
Her first reaction was,
"Take them off and give them to me."
(laughs)
- You don't realize, like, how much
such a small difference can make.
- They weren't as life changing
as I thought they would be.
And I did feel a little bit
more confident in my eyelashes.
I can see why people wanna do this,
because it was nice having
something, that's the doubt.
I did feel like my eyes were
just popping left and right.
- They were.
I think both of our
eyes were just popping.
- I mean yours were exploding.
- You guys are seeing this on the screen,
he looks like he's like
wearing some fuckin'
little Maybelline shit.
Wow!